what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg got it okay caved you got a new
beating order in the mail and I was like okay this
one is cleaner and shinier and the D's definitely
stand out more maybe this was a blessing in
disguise but I didn't get aware for last time
so anyway John how are you I'm great I'm just
happy for you thanks John cool how are you are
you saying some sort of new suit you have in your
head seems to be a worked out it's awfully red
food better too strange koi follow koi genre over
on Tick Tock 15 seconds 30 seconds 30 minute video
sometimes ten who knows leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also uh we always say this
full interaction watch long as we sync up with
your own copy available for super sexy Rejects
at our patreon page but just for you know fun
we'll make it public anyone who wants to do it
can sync up with us it's free for everyone for the
finale why not there's a link in the pin comment
and the description box lastly with that in mind
stick around for as we say thank you to G fuel for
sponsoring this video I just down to G fuel right
now actually about you could ask these guys I'm
drinking G fuel every single day it's been that
way for months so when we were asked to partner
up with them it was an instant yes because I
only want to be working with people where it's
like yeah I actually do use your product or a
version of your product and G fuel is one I use
every day I often give it to koi too it helps me
do those late night lists yeah it's gonna help
me stay up editing tonight as well so it helps
me with energy focus and right now if you use
promo code reject Nation 30 off this weekend I'm
telling you guys it's well worth it no weird crash
I'll say it sometimes unlike you know adrenaline
things it makes you and not this yeah I can vouch
normally I'm like you don't need to
oversell it but it is true so yeah thank you
Walters
oh yes accidental dose of chemistry
oh that's gross I love this angry or
outraged a startling metamorphosis occurs
what a great tribute this is so good
yes the bleacher is driven by rage I
wonder if that's the onset reference
and pursued by online trolls don't make me
angry you wouldn't like me when I'm angry
glasses
oh
what that was a hell of a
trivia man they baited you
did you and oh
oh no she's gonna go to Abominations group
therapy the hulked or the forest inhibitor
sweetheart it's all right people go to prison
every day so supportive dad oh she's gonna
really realize how much she misses being the
She-Hulk and it's gonna bring them together
get him down I don't care if there is a drought
I got water pressure for days that's an Easter
egg for the California drought one of these guys
is gonna slip up and they're gonna give us enough
information so that we can track them down and
then we will find them and we will destroy them
legally I said Bayonne no that opening was so cool
it was a lot over it yeah beautiful right after
World finite spooky season you might get a kick
out of this video that Jen and her friends made
this no no no no no She-Hulk was
twerking all the way back then this isn't
it
we're not doing a narrator we're not there
no do it please whose voice was that I'm not
running from my problems it's a mental health
break yep very La yep sometimes you got
to go to Ohio forgive me Jen for this turn
Nikki oh hey there Holt King
damn hell yeah I'll be there
are you still here I just need a place to
stay for a couple of days of course of course
I'll set you up with a guest room okay a nug
okay deep hikers you're coming in real choppy
and ladies more it guys she just sucks okay
and I'm not just saying that because she's
a female I would have the exact same criticism
if she was a man let's do it pug okay come on
come on Pros females am I right yeah
oh so happy that you're here yeah me too so happy
first he rules and he's hot and
he's hot he's hot in case you got
everything through nepotism she got
everything through nepotism exactly
you think she boned Holloway yes like you're
mad about it yeah and it pisses me off
I created Intelligentsia I'm Hulk King oh we never
saw that coming what a Twist it's okay he can
improvise oh oh no oh the guy can't Improv it's
easy just say virtue signaling and woke culture a
few times you'll get your Social Justice Warrior
but I don't think anybody can really understand
what I'm going through right now except a meal
since he went through literally the exact same
thing is the meal involved with intelligence he's
not there oh yeah yeah he's down the lodge some
private event down there oh no yeah I mean
it was evolved no give it up no oh my God
no I don't believe it oh I do believe it I
hear your group is over be making amazing
progress every single person seizing
their goal am I right Robin's Hulk hey
Jordan Peterson Hulk Jennifer
oh you've been forming into the Abomination uh
yeah I had engagements that's not me for profit
oh boy Todd created the site he's Hulk King uh
went on my blood so we could save
is he gonna become the Red Hulk or punchline Hulk
genetics don't line up man he's turning green ah
this can't possibly be where this season was going
on surprise losers what come on Titania too
I'm confused about the allegiances
it's not what you think oh rematch what
is even happening here I know I don't know
none of these storylines make any sense
is this working for you hey what do
you think you're doing you got me yeah
see
no whoa this is genius of Disney Plus
genius use of Disney plus wow holy balls
this is wild I'm so happy right now
I can't believe this has happened we've literally
walked around here yeah this is this is amazing
foreign
what the hell you guys what kind of bit finale is
this kind of a Twist a Twist the bad guy steals my
blood in order to give himself superpowers
where did you come up with that original
idea why don't we just do things our own way
this is the story that Kevin wants oh my God
are we about to talk to Kevin
no one talks to Kevin
I would murder you to protect Kevin
I'm going to go talk to Kevin now
oh my God is this happening Jesus is
this really what the floor looks like
this is New York let me just have you Center
non-disclosure agreement and then have a seat
Hulk you shouldn't read some of that Jen
ier oh we're not gonna see Kevin we
gotta see Kevin we gotta see Kevin
that I want you posters everywhere ow
ow
I want you to put away your
cell phone I need that poster
wow this is wildly meta
Kevin hello Jennifer Kevin it stands for knowledge
enhanced visual interconnectivity
buggies are you expecting a man oh
I will answer your questions but you
must first transform back to Jennifer why
you are very expensive
team hasn't gone to another project oh my
God the Black Panther's out I possess the
most advanced entertainment algorithm in the
world and it produces near perfect Products near
some are better than others but I
leave that debate up to the Internet
can we agree that it is a legal comedy
if that's what you prefer to call it
then I would like to give my closing
argument the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is known for its big spectacles and high stakes
plot lines often said that Marvel movies all in
the same way wow this is a result of following
some Unwritten rule that you have to throw a bunch
of plot and Flash and whole blood thing that seems
super suspiciously close to Super Soldier serum
distracts from the story which is
that my life fell apart right when
I was learning to be both Jen and
She-Hulk those are my Stakes Kevin
the k-e-v-i-n is processing this new
data erasing blood clot oh and and Bruce
but Bruce is supposed to return to explain what he
was doing no we don't need to hear
anything let's save it for the movie
confirmation from her oh would
not mind seeing Daredevil again
historically we've been live in that department oh
we got Tony Thor daddy issues low-key same daddy
same issue please stop oh and when
are we getting the X-Men I cannot
that's it we're done that's it you obliterated
the thrilling ending Kevin formulated
Bruce smashes buildings I smash fourth walls
and Bad Endings and sometimes when I murdered
see you on the big screen really is this gonna tie
into Captain America oh should I transform back or
is it what's the most
budget-friendly way to do this
mg you guys we are about to witness a a murderer
it's like Last Action here I'll see Court
hey Daredevil you missed it we're
done sorry everything oh man
God did they hook up with that thing
yes look at my Daredevil Beauty
that if you sign this you go back to prison
for 10 years for violating your parole yep
this show just shot up like 50 000 points
the finale was genius summer
oh my God yes yes thank you
now match Jen tells me you have your own practice
yeah in the house kitchen the Hell's Kitchen
doesn't sound like a very nice area well it's
not very glamorous but it's where I grew up and
I've always wanted to help the people in my
neighborhood who can't afford legal services
so you don't make a lot of money I I don't do it
for the money but you do make some money right Dad
it's very expensive raising kids in La I did not
think the conversations are going that way Matt
I'm going to tell you right now every conversation
is going in that direction so buckle up
I really am I'm just visiting
why not stay Welcome to My Life
no he's joining them for dinner cousin Bruce
oh my god I've been away it's a car for a while
tell you all about it but first I have
someone here that I'd like you all to meet
oh Betty my son oh my God so what what
they did it I called it there he is
oh my I just threw it in there can you share any
details about your lawsuit against Todd Phelps
and Intelligentsia people like Todd Phelps
oh Phelps this whole time you attack harm
or harass innocent people I'm coming for you
do you mean in the courtroom or as a superhero
us now tell our viewers who are
you wearing to court today okay
Luke Jacobson difficult Diva of law herself
I would have been excited that's the side
of Betty too you know it's just saying that
was a great episode that was wild as mad as
the comics get they did it like say the hope
for the movie we had a little back and forth
that they might bring Scar and I was like
they had a fast and the furious man it did
it yeah they brought him in they did that was
an incredible ending I'm so much happier with
this show now if they do a season two they gotta
keep them order like that I mean Marvel's good at
learning lessons I think and pivoting that
just like didn't even build up The Meadows
she literally went through the frame and
we got Daredevil again this did actually
move up an entire slot in my like experience of it
took your time you got stopped in
another show didn't you oh really
wongers shared fridge they're kind of all fun
with everything how about Wi-Fi I have Wi-Fi
that's a callback huh wowza wow zowza wowzers all
right we gotta talk about that [__] my God they
did a lot all right guys that was um that was the
I don't think they could beat the does that beat
the Daredevil episode what do you guys think I
don't think it beats the Daredevil said for me
no they're gonna be the Daredevil episode
I don't know why technically be the better
episode even if Daredevil's in it uh no but I
do think that it is uh to me the second best
finale of any of the Marvel shows like it was
really impressive we're gonna have Corey do a
ranking for Corey's comic corner of uh raking the
Marvel Disney Plus shows but um yeah we gotta talk
immediately about these uh these ending moments
here because it was it was such an interesting
experience because with the Intelligentsia
sequence when we were there I was like okay
this is fine like before this episode started
and we saw the Run timer like there's no way
short too short and I love that everything I
was bothered by this entire season they just
acknowledged yeah like that elevated this
in a whole show because when they're at the
intelligentsy apart and then every the whole
catastrophe of things start happening where
you know Todd's revealing himself Abominations
they're Hulk shows up Titania shows up I was
even though Jen was acknowledging to the audience
you know like this is crazy this is messy is this
what we wanted my mind was like just because
you're acknowledging it is does that mean it
doesn't make it not does that mean it's good now
because you're acknowledging it and then they went
the next extra step with breaking men like that
was more meta than than Deadpool you know in in
so many ways with walking through the Disney lot
going through the menu of the Disney plus menu
it's like this is this is like when you stand in
line for an attraction at the theme park for like
one of those Avengers rights yeah well because
they can only do this format through this show in
this way playing it on our TVs at home like that
could only exist like this yeah just like in the
comic book when like you turn a panel and there's
a surprise like that only works for that medium
and I loved the way they handled it with going to
the writer's room making fun of every step of the
way of how we've handled things so far and then
messing with this on Kevin feige and then even it
works in such a meta level with turning Kevin
into an AI into an entity of like what people
like it's already sort of like what you imagined
by the brain of Kevin feige must actually work
but they were acknowledging like everything in
that direct X-Men would ask that the X-Men ask
um what people think about the Marvel finales like
they've paid attention so much to the comments the
lack of sex in the MCU more Daredevil would be
nice as well and like here's how your finales of
the Disney Plus shows tend to go there's a formula
I I really respected I feel like some people might
they'll do their think pieces and they'll do their
video USA saying how they went too far with the
metaness because but I think they I loved it I
thought they did such an excellent job and then
when they went back into the actual show itself
and then had such a heartwarming ending with oh
man they even brought up too with Hulk of like
we didn't either this is like teasing that we're
gonna get another Hulk movie yeah doing a tease
like that is so ingenious instead of an Easter
egg they're like yeah you know it's coming yeah
so much more fun clever super clever and then
having Daredevil sit down with them and teasing
the possibility then having like an actual maybe
longer lasting romance than just a little fling
that's why koi wanted a date again I did fall in
love again and Matt came back as he fell in love
with love again too yeah and plus you demanded it
and I'm not mad at that she made it happen with
Kevin feige AI machine the Kevin Modoc parallel
that was that was so good genius oh my God I want
to see her in Deadpool work together now uh and
then yeah what's and so now we're at the post
credit scene what sense do you make of that uh I
feel like the post-credits scene is I think that
Wong might be helping assemble the Thunderbolts
and not realize it I think there's gonna be a
certain like they're gonna bring it back he's
gonna be Thunderbolts officially I think he's I
think he's gonna be in the Thunderbolts nomination
that's been the main Theory but I mean it makes
sense and he's been Gathering people people like
we've seen block Gathering people for like five
movies so like is it gonna be dark Avengers or
Thunderbolts is it maybe he's Gathering people to
fight the Thunderbolts which side is abomination
going to be on fascinating because I think that
like there's gonna be two sets of teams I think
One's Gonna end up being a Dark Avenger or a young
Avenger and one's gonna be the one that are called
Thunderbolts but I think the Thunderbolts is going
to be a bait and switch wherein those are all
reformed characters if you look at the assemblage
of team we got at d23 all of those people have
been in therapy and like they're working on their
stuff so what if the Thunderbolt twist is they all
think they're actually doing good and then they
find out their villains instead of us as the
audience finding out these villains are here the
the people we've identified as heroes or villains
what if the characters think they're doing right
and they find out they've been doing things wrong
and that would be a switch on the concept of
thunderbolts true and that'd be a really fun way
to do it like I think I'm doing something right
I'm doing this I'm doing this oh wait I'm working
for the enemy I'm a thunderbolt and that subverts
expectation for Comic fans and viewers yeah look
at this look at the scar in a second but what do
you think John I think about which part about this
Thunderbolts about the post-credits scene or
this the Enemy No I mean why my only question
then is if Wong is uh you know organizing a team
or whatever where does that leave characters like
Shang Chi and Katie and things like that who are
confirmed to be like other Avengers um and the
power Broker Than The Power broker everyone's
wondering coming back at some point the Fisto
and the power broker top two most request I mean
yeah this seems like a shotgun blast of setups I
don't really know what to pin as like that's
definitely coming or not I think it would be
really interesting to see a movie that takes place
in between the events of something else we already
know like we know if there is some kind of other
Hulk movie that fills in this blank about how
he finds Scar and brings him back you know he's
obviously going to come back with him from that
you know that we know that from you know watching
this so I feel like it would be an interesting
way to kind of see the timeline expand because
I feel like there's a relatively linear way in
which that has gone up until now with a couple
notable exceptions whereas now I feel like you
could almost draw from anywhere on the timeline
and thus free yourself up that much more in light
of something like this I wish that we had to that
we got to see Bruce Banner and Daredevil interact
with each other I wish we actually got that
because sometimes they shoot these scenes in in uh
in the Marvel movies and stuff where they're not
even in the same room and they're gonna say who
they're talking to but she says that's my cousin
to uh Charlie Cox so I'm like so he that's what I
was like oh are they actually gonna talk yeah but
how great is it like this deep into phase four now
it's just people meeting again like we've got all
new meet cute like in Phase One like there's all
these new characters I thought because when scars
usually scar can be like pretty uh scarves like a
big is intense yeah and I was thinking as being
like this monolith yeah exactly not like a woman
he had such a such a childlike teenager quality
and a very silly haircut like a teenager yes my
first guess was Betty because I thought my now
I didn't I thought they were I thought because
the show was saying we'll Reserve everything for
the whole country yeah I was like because you're
seeing relationships and [__] I just wanted
someone to crack a Corona who is playing scar
God that's like I'm trying to pinpoint the
face because it's such a good CGI it looks
great it does I mean the CGI on this episode
definitely improved they gave him some time
I feel like it might be a dream just young
Mark Ruffalo I did enjoy the fact they gave
us that wakanda uh sound cue and they were like
the artist went on to another project already
yeah who is that it looks like it'd just be
Mark Ruffalo he's handsome I see I'm sitting
here going I feel like I've seen that face that
face yeah now I can't Peg it I wonder if the
credits say who played him I wonder if they'd
even write SCAR or if that would be like a leak
uh man yeah I mean we all thought it would be
scarf from the with them you and I made a video
about it yeah a lot of people made videos about
we can't but we can't be the only one we are the
only people we're the only people the concepts no
one had the idea until we came along wait there
are other comic book commentaries I don't think so
okay I mean that's the whole point I think we'll
click here koi you're drunk I don't want people
and they also when they went to the the metaverse
that it went uh trademark Facebook yeah then they
went into uh they went into like an IMAX ratio for
it yeah I really enjoyed the frame expanding
to be more realistic because you know you're
watching this with frame you don't notice it and
then when it expands it feels Larger than Life it
feels like it's reaching out to you they also use
really interesting angles so like in a comic book
A lot of times when you break the fourth wall
they've got to change the dynamic of the frame
so it looks different I really like that they were
able to do that with extreme high and low shots so
it feels like a different Dynamic of show does it
feel though like a satisfying I guess my question
is is a series as a whole other despite how great
those last two episodes are first two last two
exception and five in the middle that's my that's
my thing is like this this to me improved the five
in the middle because a lot of my issues were the
writing and the thinness and this acknowledged it
but in the same way that you acknowledge that her
just saying something doesn't make me feel better
about it I don't know where I land on it because
of that yeah I feel like I've weirdly felt like I
want to go back and re-watch this because as much
as they made all the jokes about it that I thought
were really clever I'm like but does the character
journey of Jen Walters truly Click by the end John
your thoughts I would like to see this episode
again and the season as a whole again but yeah
I mean I will never forget the experience of of
beholding this for the first time I am so happy
in this moment I was overjoyed by the choices they
were making however I'm curious on a re-watch how
this will feel as yeah a complete story a complete
package because I could have watched this for 10
more minutes I could have watched more of a lot
of these scenes and I mean yeah she has her square
off with Kevin and rewrites everything and then
we kind of snap to the conclusion from there so
it's really thrilling to watch this whole meta
interlude go down but I am also curious just to
to note yeah after a re-watch or or in a couple
of days how I'll feel kind of as a if this is a
well-rounded episode or if it's just a very bold
episode you know yeah because it's like the last
two were so solid in the way and what they were
setting out to do that I feel like they're the
direction the writing the TLC and what they wanted
to accomplish there was so spot on but we were
still before we were gonna go this meta we were
still had a primary story we were aiming to tell
and it's like does that this is the core of that
still truly captured because what was the what was
it again accepting herself but was that struggle
a real struggle that we had to I mean I think she
had to accept herself as Jen and then she had
to accept herself as she all because then she
had to accept if Jen and shield could co-exist
and that was kind of the it's kind of just like
a I wonder not really uh so it's interesting
this is the first show that like uh most the
six episode show I want to be nine and this one
I I kind of would have been cool with it being
like a tighter six like if it was two two and then
like the five episodes in the middle were like the
dating instead of necessarily the magic like they
could have just like you know maybe or even like
45 minutes six episodes like something about out
the way this felt like the the length of it with
the punch line maybe that's my issue because it
feels like a year ago the journey began because
you know how like Deadpool 2 as an example of a
movie that goes Super meta yeah still has a full
character Arc for Wilson in that movie and how and
then like even uh if you get some Deadpool too I
don't need to recap the whole thing it just it
does go all meta and it's like post credit scenes
especially but there is still a full Journey that
he goes on there that you can really feel for
and by the end of this as as dazzled as I was by
what they decided to go with the last thing I was
really feeling for was oh yeah and Jen's Journey
was kind of like the last thought of the journey
that she had I mean were you guys personally
let me clarify again I think Tatiana maslani
one of the best castings Marvel has ever done
yeah the scene especially with her human with
Kevin she's phenomenal absolutely phenomenal but
yeah do you feel the um the emotional character
art was truly honestly I feel like the closure
was gotten before this episode so this is the
real answer like I feel like I'm like I know what
her Arc was I felt that closure this was like a
denuma of of spectacle yeah in a new way while
acknowledging it wasn't the Spectrum very solid
so I I think we got the experience and then this
gave us the by the way it's a shield show yeah
so it worked it's still not like in my top watch
the episode it's when we listened like there are
reasons it doesn't quite work as well as other
things but this is the only medium and only way
they could have done this and I respect that true
true and she does accept that she is it's like
yeah we saw we knew that we knew the obvious gang
going with the meta and that's and the awareness
that we knew the trajectory would be like she
would accept that both Jen and She-Hulk and then
early on in this episode she's like oh yeah I do
watch Eagle Creek that's all we needed I'm like
yeah we knew it was going there and I really liked
intelligencia and stuff that I was like I don't
even think of those characters like my brain never
comprehended it and I was like why would they go
that way and then this being like dismissive of
it it's exactly what the message boards were yeah
like they did that really well and even if
it wasn't man I would still have the same
thing this must have been a fun episode I cannot
imagine like all the throwaway dialogue they got
to just toss around in that room that was a
hilarious ass line yeah I've definitely said
that before though about certain characters I feel
like I have to if I criticize some characters I'm
like guys Frick free come at me I would still say
this but I didn't say that about Jane I thought
she was great it becomes a meme Trope you know it
all phrases like that start out earnestly enough
it's like in the context of how you use that
phrase which is the beauty of even the writer's
room stuff right like they were able to bring
awareness to not just the other side of cringe
culture but the writing culture and the the fourth
wall break I thought was just so masterfully done
because it kept finding new walls right like
so first you got her acknowledging the Disney
plus of it all then literally kicking through
things and then she stays aware so that answers
the who she been talking to the whole thing and
that's what's gonna be interesting for me is like
where we go forward with her like how much is
she gonna be aware like how omnipresent is Jen
Walters and how much can her awareness affect
affect whatever property like if she steps into
The Avengers movie you know I don't want coosco to
pause the movie you know what I mean like I don't
want I don't want that actually solid pool there
man yeah emperor's new group slept on Disneyland
get some Emperor's New Groove merch I'd buy it
uh because yeah that is a really great question
and but we gotta talk about that opening as well
that opening was genius I love how they did the
tie that's okay that also ties the ending a 70s
opening and then you've got bookends yeah I didn't
even put that together until right now yeah it's
a perfect bookend um because yeah stepping into
the mind of Jen Walters but I remember being a
kid and not fully understanding the build up of
frustration but when when David Banner um starts
turning into the Hulk after unsuccessfully he's
able to change his tire yes so it always made me
laugh like so good that was the turning point for
like a cop friend like there's been a buildup of
[__] happening I was like oh that's what did it
right does not like tires really specifically
turned into a monster I'll never forget that
and they even learn some motion in like actual
physical makeup that was so good and her just like
yelling at the car that shot was genius I wonder
if that's the onset reference because they always
credit the onset reference actress for that yeah
with some extra yeah just some extra uh and also
and I said it earlier but I think the balance of
effectively for scar being five hulks in this they
did a lot of really good work uh making them look
good and different yeah like that the skin looked
great this episode even in the light oh man also
that too it's about the VFX no and a black panther
joke like well and I was like I wonder how the
VFX artists feel about this I could only imagine
them sitting there going huh we are so tired
oh I imagine that there was a bit of there's
gotta be a tad bit of a catharsis within the joke
there always heard things are improving because
again when she's even when even Kevin says like
they've moved on to other things already so could
you gotta change back to normal you know it's
kind of letting the audience know that there's
sometimes these business decisions that are made
which I really do we're going from this to wakanda
Forever whatever that's like probably the weirdest
that might be the weirdest tonal shift in the MCU
history yeah I guess the question is is like did
it what will the effects of this have would it
would have gone too meta well season two is all
a dream sequence yeah confirmed I'm I'm really
curious what the internet does uh I mean obviously
The Internet's been exhausting with this whole
show but I'm really curious like it is polarizing
to do a meta self-awareness thing to this level
but Kevin talking to everybody Kevin loves
everybody talks to everybody that's the difference
with the real life Kevin Kevin feige you're great
we appreciate you and your omnipress people are
always talking about Kevin fighting I'm just kind
of talking with everyone all the time yeah uh uh
I loved it I I want to re-watch this episode I I
feel like these last two episodes it's stuff that
was truly special and even though I think the
Daredevil episode is a better narrative story
that's why when you ask me I'm like yeah like I
like meta but I also like contained story like
this is probably the most personally affecting but
I I love what they were able to do by bringing in
Daredevil so like 1000 yeah because I think that
you know like while that Daredevil episode of
course is so special and near and dear to our
hearts yeah this is what this episode is what
made She-Hulk the show incredibly special and and
it was able to retroactively make me appreciate a
lot of the choices I wasn't enjoying and like
down to the details of like knowing certain
Marvel references that only die hards would get
versus The Casual jokes versus all those like
little things like and also I can't even imagine
writing this and knowing that you're reading all
this trolling leading up to like what's to come
or like you know Kevin feige shepherding all this
forward and then knowing that there's gonna
be a Kevin that is referenced in this way and
they're writing around this and like what was that
approval of that script like what was Kevin feige
reading the Kevin dialogue and like because he's
so invested like when I introduced you guys too
much Spider-Man like he's so fat like what are
the reactions what's the experience how are you
guys enjoying like he cares about this so much
no yeah that was the first thing I thought of
was like what I would love to hear an interview
with him about this deep dive because it's such
a unique that's like he's the only producer that
has this happened yeah and it also felt like there
was a sort of legitimate um like not danger but
you know like if you're being meta from within
your own house there are surely things that you
cannot say that people should be thinking yeah
uh that's when I developed my drinking problems
but uh yeah like it still felt um for lack of a
better word you know like his kind of flirting
with the line and kind of dangerous in where
they were going with those meta things and so
like hats like you can always go further you
can always skewer harder but I was like oh hats
off to you know at least going as far as you did
and I would love to know what the approval process
for that was like and I love the Matrix of it all
like I felt like the architect yeah I almost I
almost threw that out there but I was so wrapped
so phase seven will be the after Multiverse
Saga it's gonna be the the metaverse oh 100 yeah
Kevin feige dead Hulk
um all right guys well what did you think about
this man that was wild that was freaking wild
um I can't wait to see like I was telling you
before you showed up I was like look man I I
there are people who apparently they've read some
leaks and I was like I haven't I haven't read them
um I would have guessed some things on camera to
make myself seem smart like is she investigation
I wouldn't believe this league I was like I heard
their leaks are crazy so we got to make sure I was
like telling like koi like maybe we wanted to film
something afterwards or something yeah and I got
here early and like stayed off my phone I was like
I don't want to see anything on the journey yeah I
have friends who rather like these things are true
this is crazy and I I was like okay so what like
she like red hulks that's what I was like he's
ready is that what's gonna happen that's where
my mind was going of like what characters could
show up that would make this a crazy finale when
you said crazy I was like Deadpool is the fourth
wall break yeah that's that's how you Safeguard
yourself from leaks just make yes make the
reality sound way too outlandish to be true but
then uh but man that was I I would my mind never
ventured it would go that wild like this is beyond
whatever people delivery yeah they delivered like
describing that story is not as good as what they
showed and that's so a last bit sorry last rant
the thing the thing I was talking okay the thing
I always talk about with these things is the MCU
is different from the comics right I always use
Civil War as an example and like the way you keep
these things fresh is you have it evolve from the
medium for the medium so what worked in Civil War
the comic doesn't necessarily work in Civil War
the movie what's great about The Shield episode
is this showed us why these things should be on
Disney Plus versus in the theater I've been saying
like I'd rather have things in the movie theater
I've been saying I'd rather have these experiences
this just showed me the benefit of the medium of
watching something at home in a way that I never
would have expected with the only character that
made that work so this is so unique to Disney
plus to me and just warmed my heart that you
could even prove me completely wrong I'm so happy
this lives here and it's really sold that moment
where you cut back to the menu I could feel the
tension in the room when you go back to the Disney
plus menu it's like I was like oh [__] this is
gonna be so hard to re-sync before I can feel it
oh God it's gonna be so stressful so as much as I
would love to as much as this is the episode I'm
like I wish I could see this on a big screen with
some of that scope change I'm like this is also
like really well suited to its medium yeah I mean
you wouldn't exactly because of the scope change
that's the main reason why but um that kick that
first kick I I can't wait to watch us go and then
see her like saying through because that's that's
something that could only happen here and then
we're watching us watch our fourth wall break 16
walls guys what did you think about this episode
uh leave your thoughts down below subscribe click
that Bell leave a like uh let's see who the lucky
patron of the day shout out is Fox you are the
She-Hulk of this channel you are a badass you are
a virtuous human being and if there's anybody
I would love to see break our fourth wall and
change some things around maybe for the better I
think it would be you you got good judgment you
got good taste you're somebody who I feel like
is supportive but Stern you would take us in the
right direction it would be mad cat but it would
be beautiful my dear and I hope you're doing well
out there stay beautiful stay sexy and we'll talk
to you soon much love I advantage of the list you
will never been shouted out congratulations
folks you just got the finale be happy